savoir reconnaître les champignons les
insectes reconnaître les traces du
passage d'un écureuil à la façon dont il
a grignoté une pomme de pain la forêt
c'est un écosystème fragile qui regorge
de richesses naturelles
il faut donc savoir la comprendre
l'observer pour pouvoir la respecter le
temps d'une balade solène boivin guide
au sein du parc naturel régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse a pu nous
faire découvrir les nombreuses espèces
protégées dont regorge le site
une balade de chaînes en être majestueux
bercé par le chant des oiseaux et le son
du vent dans les feuilles en tant que
guide de parc à jeux propose des visites
guidées sur différentes thématiques ça
peut être des thématiques qui concernent
le petit patrimoine
bien sûr l'environnement le
développement durable et ce sur le
territoire du parc naturel régional de
la haute vallée de chevreuse ce pnr
compte trois réserves naturelles et il y
en a une quatrième qui qui est en cours
de création qui concerne les étangs de
hollande et
et les rigoles également il ya également
le petit moulin de vaux de cernay qui
est un site assez remarquable il est
dans un environnement qui est très riche
avec plus de 217 espèces de plantes à
fleurs
alors je propose également des balades
pour un public familial qui s'appelle
les petits curieux assez dans différents
endroits du pnr il ya différentes
espèces dans sa liste des balades sont
organisées pour tous les publics
scolaires ou adultes en groupes ou
individuels
le pnr les propose tout au long de
l'année pour faire découvrir la faune et
la flore de ces espaces